noi non ho preso tante cose sarai sono
solo al terzo mese per ora preso solo
col passeggino motorino macchina
investiti a 0 18 anni giusto
residenziale noi non ce la faccia non ce
la farò mai a partorirò troppa paura
online sta adesso il mio bambino e l'ho
saputo un pomodoro pachino anzi no
adesso ha cambiato risulta fuori sughero
e
combattimento ha messo in b è ma lui
sarà tutto la mamma concerto grosso già
si vede dalle corro via po troppo fatto
vedere ancora che riguarda vedi allo
stesso nesi lo è anche il mio alluce
valgo fa male ma quanta da 1 a 10 noi
senza pitturare con partoriscono non gli
stand quinto report non lo guarda bassa
niente vomito proprio sempre la nuvola
mi scopro così grazie volentieri
devo trovare la vostra per l'ospedale lo
so che sono al quarto mese infatti manca
pochissimo la casa da cinque mesi guarda
che il tempo vola è un attimo a dormire
ho capito che mi sono appena svegliata
ma ho sonno cosa si possa fare tanto
sonno volta sola